je vais juste me montrer que les
dessins initiaux et les trucs que j'ai totalement inversés et
je n'ai pas pensé une minute à ce que cela
allait réellement signifier pour moi physiquement
en termes de comment nous allions y
parvenir au quotidien, je suis mis à l'intérieur de
toi  je sais une cagoule en caoutchouc qui est ensuite
collée à mon visage et il y a beaucoup de
prothèses, donc le maquillage est en fait
incroyablement rapide, je pense que pour ce qui est
accompli, c'est environ une heure
et demie, puis il y a un
costume de muscle robot qui se passe à où un
combinaison de refroidissement qui a une tuyauterie qui va tout
autour de moi et ils la branchent et de l'
eau glacée la traverse et me garde au frais
si peu à l'intérieur du gin
tonic que je n'entends pas très bien parce
que j'ai ce truc sur mon  tête et
il n'y a qu'une partie de ma propre peau
montrant qu'il m'a fallu quelques jours pour le
comprendre, vous savez, nous avons fait quelques
trous pour que je puisse en quelque sorte entendre la
conversation et je lis beaucoup